well who doesn't love an edible
arrangement right rocky stop by a local
shop for some fresh fruit and ideas for
holiday gifting this year
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hi welcome to edible arrangement my name
is basil daniel and this is the south
rainbow location
as we know the holidays are approaching
fast and we are known to help our
communities celebrate with their loved
ones with the best gifts ideas that we
have for them so we do have eight stores
in las vegas
and we deliver all over the valley and
you can come to the stores and get any
items you want or you can go to
edible.com and place your orders there
and you can pick them up at the store or
have them delivered in our refrigerated
vans one of my favorite gifts to give
and receive is an edible arrangement so
i'm so excited to talk about your be
sweet campaign for the holidays what do
you have for us baby oh the bee sweet
that's what we're sharing with our
community is basically for thanksgiving
and christmas thanksgiving we have the
salted caramel thanksgiving bouquet
featuring the turkey and all the sweets
in it and we have the number one seller
gobble gobble platter too cute and over
here i'm recognizing some of your
original items but
cheese yes this is the christmas
selection we have we have the christmas
platter we have the jolly village
different sizes for all the budgets we
have the the double decker box we have
our regular boxes and we have the
curated box that has cheese jelly nuts
the new
peppermint popcorn and our penguin for
christmas that is so good and when
people are coming in obviously you can
order online pre-order but people can
also walk in and grab on the go right
yeah we have the grab and go items so we
have a lot of stuff we have our bake
shop that we have cupcakes cheesecakes
cookies and we do have smoothies as well
that we make i saw that i already
ordered one yeah and then
banana we do have flowers that they can
make and if something we don't have our
shelf we can make something in 10
minutes or 15 depending on the size and
how much difficult is involved in it
perfect well happy holidays happy hour
to you guys
well thank you to edible arrangements
for sponsoring this segment we have
eight las vegas henderson edible
locations for more information you can
just head to edible.com and remember
they offer free next day delivery we'll
be right back